this is the oni oven this is the uni
oven why don't
you have it hitting like that though
hey everybody it's nicole russell from
last dragon pizza
welcome to pizza wars on first week
feast this season has been my personal
hero's journey as i work to become the
world's next top pizza master
i've won i've lost but now i need to
battle the
final boss master piece of chef vito
iacopelli
hello guys my name is vito yacobelli
and i'm a fourth generation pizzaiolo
from my mom's side
and third generation pizza chef from my
father's side today
i'm going to make a very very special
pizza
neapolitan style of course but it's
going to be slightly different
with a canotto style kanoto style is the
pizza
with a nice big cross made with a
pre-fermented dough that makes the dough
soft and crunchy in the same time
there's no better arena for the showdown
than right here where it all started
my home in rockaway queens i started my
journey at home working to perfect the
art of pizza making in my home
kitchen now vito and i are using the
unicode of 16 to cook the ultimate
neapolitan style pies in my backyard
plus food review legend dame drops is
coming by later to crown a winner
one thing i have to say to nicole nicole
i flew from italy
to new york so for sure i'm going to
show you something special
vito you're a legend you're the maestro
you're the boss but guess what
you're in rockaway today my stomping
grounds and i'm gonna take you down
[Music]
vito is in the building all the way from
italy i'm
so excited thank you so much for being
here
you're first my man thank you nicole
thank you it's a pleasure for me to be
here today so vito what are you making
today i see some purple stuff over there
let's go
i'm making something special something
with purple potato
roasted bacon that i'm gonna go ahead
and roast it right now on this so man
vito do they put bacon on pizza in italy
to be honest
i'm italian 110 but i like to eat the
american breakfast oh so i like the
texture of
and the taste of the the bacon so why
not put it on the pizza that's right
voila oh yes voila that bacon is ready
to go
so now we're gonna put this on the side
and i'm ready to make the pizza okay are
you ready
i don't know if i'm ready but i gotta
get ready don't i pay attention
i'm paying attention watch and learn so
first of all i mix the flower with
semolina okay
oh my goodness you're gonna be gentle
it's like a touching a woman you know
yes
gentle look at that oh that's it that
woman would love that oh yeah
there we go almost forgot the crust
that's why so special is pizza the crust
fill up with ricotta
oh my goodness voila
now get the bacon put it inside the
crust i've never seen anyone put bacon
inside the crust before
that's why i'm here today to show you
something unique so
now the base is going to be a little bit
of a strachatella cheese
now we put the smoked mozzarella
now are you ready i'm ready voila oh my
goodness that's the special thing right
here we're gonna put a
purple potato oh my god in a way that
we're gonna make it rain
make it rain make a rain voila
make a rain to all the pizza just like
the pecorino cheese everywhere
and now extra virgin olive oil a little
bit just like that
voila now it's the time watch this
little bit of flour you all the right
here and then one shot it's a maestro
so are you ready i'm ready okay put your
glass on
and wash wow
voila one shot usually cooks in about
one minute and a half too
[Music]
[Music]
that's what we want soft and crunchy at
the same time
okay i need a piece okay nicole so it's
too way to eat the pizza yes this is one
way
typical and the other way i call it
canola
so what i do open the crust wash this
and we roll the pizza
inside the crust oh my goodness
voila all right cheers oh my god
so let's taste this pizza it's a little
hot
this cheese is amazing i can taste the
smokiness
it tastes so good the cheese tastes like
butter seriously well i've had
neapolitan pizza in naples
and i've never had a pizza this good
special it's special oh my gosh
i can't wait to see yours now well i'm
gonna make my pizza and i hope you enjoy
it you ready of course
so vito you're here in rockaway and i'm
gonna make you one of my top pies that i
make in rockaway called
the seventh heaven it's usually a
tandoori or tikka
pizza uh-huh today i'm gonna use lamb so
first of all what i'm gonna do i have my
dough here
it looks good i'm gonna take some samola
mix a little regular flour
and then i'm gonna just open this up so
this piece is like new york
neapolitan yes when i went to italy i
learned a lot about neapolitan pizza
basically how delicate it is it's such a
science and
technique over there you know so i hope
i get to do you guys a little
justice so i'm gonna add my sauce to
this just a little bit
this is american mozzarella it's from
grande and i'm just gonna put a little
cheese on here a little more cheese
fantastic
i'm going to add a little bit of onion
put a little tomato on here
i'm going to take my lamb the secret
ingredient the secret ingredient
and i'm just going to lay it on here so
what i did earlier was i seared the lamb
in the uni cast iron in the oni
so you're basically a little bit roasted
too yeah a little bit roast the lamb
just to get it started right
then wait taste i put it in this curry
so now we're going to put this in here
when it's good yes
put one shot
nicole i've been teaching people you're
doing a really great job i like i love
it what we're gonna do is
we're gonna top this with a little
cilantro squeeze a little lime on here
let me taste let me know i don't want to
talk anymore let's cut the pizza and
give it there i need to come here just
to taste your pizza
oh thank you so let's go for it all
right one two
three
[Music]
you like it let me enjoy this moment
[Laughter]
wow i really love it it's really good i
personally like a lot of flavor i love
them this pizza
you really nail it oh thank you so much
i'm not joking the lamb
this sauce right there it's yes
[Music]
vito your pizza was incredible oh i'm
still eating it's flattering that you
love my pizza but we got to go to the
judges table
we've got dame drops here and he's the
host of fresh fried and crispy or
netflix oh i shouldn't make a fried
pizza
that's what we should have did we're so
slow okay it's gonna be a thai
competition
oh he says he's gonna be tight he's so
sweet
[Music]
dame thank you so much for being here i
really want to know what's your ideal
slice of pizza hit you with it i need
that thin crust
action and i want my crust to be
seasoned up i need that cheese to look
like a jungle gym just
swinging i pick my piece up and cheese
is just still connected
you know what i'm saying it's bonded
with the rest of the pie like a
relationship
just holding on for great light you know
what i mean i need bacon
still to be crisp even though it's all
within the cheese so when i take a bite
it's a salty cheesy flair happiness
makes me want to go back in for more but
that's
my thing oh my gosh wow that was a real
let's go damn i'm so happy you're here
vito and i made two amazing pies but
vito
you go first today i'm gonna bring you
to naples oh like that just with a slice
you close your eyes
and boom you go to naples this pizza you
eat in two
different ways okay okay but what i
prefer is to
eat the pizza like a canola there's a
whole lot of loving
sitting between my fingertips i'm trying
to go to italy with this one that's what
you say i'm traveling right
pizza is lifestyle you know pizza is a
lifestyle yes
me to my man let me tell you something
yes what's up i've had a lot of pizzas
in my time good brother
this whole entire cannoli style of
breaking a pie down has been the very
first time for your boy
it seemed as if you have created a
masterpiece within
that cannoli style pizza when they see
it v they can't eat it the regular way
they see that bacon
and they see that purple potato action
popping on top of the cheese right there
they see the crust
the crust is a must number flavor on top
of flavor i'm highly excited
you've taken it to the next level of
pizza brothers
next level pizza who says this is this
is a uni oven
this is the only oven why don't you have
it hitting like that though
now when owner can go ahead and serve up
the type of heat to give you pizza on
top of pizza
on top of pizza you know you eating
something sincere something so
serious i took more bites than just a
little bit
might even go back for more
dame you seem super happy oh yeah but
i'm gonna make you even happier
yep your girls got you i'm gonna make
you a tandoori
lamb pizza that we call seventh heaven
you ready
seven heaven who let me go there
okay let's go there real quick
wild cheesy that cheese dream is
definitely in the building
that's what i love at the end of the day
right that lamb
came in a nice 10 defender bender had a
little spice so nice
but that little lime that zesty flint
and kicked up it was like hold on don't
worry about the spice we got you
we're gonna comfort the pallet this
pizza right here had
had me at a loss for words momentarily
which is hard to do
because my mouth was working in with so
many different flavors
and that's what you provide that's what
i see your customers love
all the flavor on a pie like that's
important nicole you don't dig your
thing
thank you
so damn i've been working all season up
to this moment
it's up to you who's the winner
physician
oh man my man vito came in
he had my bacon never faking i love that
he brought me a transformer pizza
you ain't never had transforming pizza
before i promise you
nicole said dame who was the last time
you had some lamb and yogurt just
chilling together
on the dance floor partying up under the
same roof i said never
but that flavor was crazy this is
difficult
but at the end of the day somebody has
to win
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
place this award in front of the pie
that best satisfied my taste buds that
put me in a good head space
that had me begging for more this bad
boy's about to go
you making a down oh my gosh
[Music]
oh my gosh which way will it go
oh oh excellent job
vito greatly appreciate you but those
flavors right there that did it for your
boy
so this is the finale for the season i
can't believe i did a finale with dame
drops and
vito yo capelli oh my god i worked so
hard this season
and i had nothing but people that would
push me to the limits
so everyone that participated thank you
so much
i'm so grateful i really do want to be a
master of pisola
and i'm about to cry because i'm just so
honored for real
amazing job you did a really good job
you know thank you guys so much
and i see you next time on peace awards
you